avec ses canaux et ses 131 pont
montargis la venise du gâtinais attire
les plaisanciers en haute saison et pour
mettre en valeur ce patrimoine
l'agglomération entend bien se doter
d'une marina digne de son surnom sur le
quai où les voitures stationnent
actuellement on aura effectivement on va
creuser un petit peu pour élargir la
voie et la voie d'eau et on va pouvoir
mettre en perpendiculaire quelques
caisses l'otan qui permettront
effectivement de pouvoir accueillir des
petits bateaux et pour les grands
bateaux ils seront en linéaire en amont
et en aval du site et ça va bien se
passer
la capacité d'accueil du port actuel
passeraient de 20 à 60 emplacements un
projet à 10 milliards d'euros
nécessaires sur cette portion du canal
d'après les voies navigables de france
le gestionnaire du réseau
on a une un port assez important à
briare au sud du canal de briare après
tout le long du réseau on avait des
petites haltes fluviales
mais pas une infrastructure assez
importante et
comme comme pourra peut-être le projet
de marina avantage
cette année plus de 350 bateaux ont
emprunté le canal et traverser la venise
du gâtinais permettre aux plaisanciers
de débarquer plus facilement profiterait
au commerce local que ça te permettra
d'avoir un éventail plus large de
touristes puisque la région parisienne
et particulièrement demanderesse de deux
visites de promenade sur le canal
le conseil départemental du loiret a
déjà débloqué 5 millions d'euros soit la
moitié du budget les travaux pourraient
commencer en 2019